you can call in we are not screening
calls for only particular topics or
questions or trolling or critiques I
don't know who's going to be on the line
and let's start there who's who am I
talking to here hi David this is Alex
from New Jersey Alex what can we do for
you today so David I want to declare my
colors first
I am a libertarian but I absolutely love
your podcast I think that you guys
really would you do is you provide a
critique of Trump that most people don't
I think it's just kind of name-calling
but I think it's really good to go to
you guys for the Trump news that's
shocking that we even need to do a
critique of someone who should not even
be on the national stage but listen he
is and we're doing the critique so thank
you what's on your mind today so really
what I want to know is um I want to know
kind of where you stand on Hillary
Clinton and this isn't something I've
really heard you talk about at any real
length yeah I'm not really sure if you
are a Hillary fan because you kind of
see her as the more lesser of two evils
I mean I know this is a liberal podcast
but I'm not sure if you see her more as
the lesser of two evils figure or you
actually are a true Hillary fan so I
just kind of wanted to hear a little bit
more about what you thought about that
no I am NOT a quote through Hillary fan
I mean certainly Hillary Clinton is very
very much to my right I've just been
very clear that you know I think Gary
Johnson is not qualified to be president
I believe that Jill Stein has numerous
issues on which I think she both is
wrong and is completely unqualified
period to hold national elected office
so right now where I'm at is protest
votes aside balancing whether a third
party vote in Massachusetts could or
could not swing the election from one
candidate to another right now
considering everything that is sort of
out there I will be voting for Hillary
Clinton because I believe that of the
people that are currently running
balancing their experience their views
their positions and the predictability
of what it is that they will do I
believe that Hillary Clinton is
the person that on November 9th would be
most relieving for me to see as the next
president of the United States now that
does people will email me right Alex and
they'll say David you're you're
complicit in Hillary's neoconservative
war mongering well no I'm not my
statement does not say that I am in
agreement with any particular one of
Hillary Clinton's policies it's more
that where we are today any other result
on November 9th would be more concerning
to me I I hope that answers the question
yeah no I appreciate the clarification I
mean I think you know regardless of
where we may differ on policies I just
love that you always keep it
intellectual and that's one of the
reasons why you know I continue to
listen you time and time again
so I appreciate where New Jersey's are
you calling from by the way anywhere I'd
know I'm far from the Jersey Shore
brielle if you know her that is the
little south of Asbury Park okay yeah I
might my band tin fingers that I played
in when I lived in Brooklyn played a
show in Asbury Park at a place called
the you know what I don't remember the
name of the place but they had a go
probably The Stone Pony not Stone Pony
was the other one oh I'm not sure I
don't know I hadn't seen a concert there
in a while but they're another couple
venues over there so if I said very cool
Duff so good to hear thank you so much
for taking the call little David Pakman
show trivia for you there okay thank you
so much for the call we are going to
move on we are taking calls today's
Gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to game
fly offered.com / TDPS